[Music]  that cover is amazing what did you think  about that honor I thought it was  awesome and I'm super grateful that they  chose me to be the woman of their year  and it was fun we had a lot of fun  shooting discover you can clearly see  the gal was playful and carefree during  her GQ photo shoot with a touch of that  smoldering sexiness gal is one of four  separate covers the 32 year old tells ET  the sequel to Wonder Woman will start  filming soon and she was pregnant with  her second child while shooting the last  three months of Justice League so if  that's not a Wonder Woman then we don't  know what is it's been such a and  amazing crazy ride that I think I'm  gonna guess what's happening only in two  years from now  Justice League opens on Friday go see it  [Music]  you